as Congress tries to pass the budget
deal and avoid that government shutdown
a split has been exposed among top
Democrats on Capitol Hill correspondent
Peter Doocy has the story of Nancy
Pelosi versus Chuck Schumer the top two
Democrats in Congress both gave their
input to Republican counterparts who
were writing this spending deal but the
left side of the table left the talks
split the Senate's leader wants people
to vote yes it'll be easy to say well I
didn't like this I didn't like that but
this is a time to come together but the
house is leader says she's gonna vote no
I'm not pleased with the process a
people vote for it now now some loyal
House Democrats are following her lead
yeah I support what does Nancy Pelosi
said and I'm gonna vote against it on
the Senate side some Democrats aren't
sure why Pelosi is ditching her own deal
we can't control the discussion in the
house I'm sure there's gonna be a
variety of opinions in the House of
Representatives this morning Senate
Minority Leader Schumer saluted Pelosi's
eight hour-long protest of the deal he
still supports leader Pelosi shouldn't
have to stand and speak for eight hours
I respect her for doing it in a Dear
Colleague letter to lawmakers Pelosi
stresses she's going to vote no because
her letter says quote we have always
said nothing is agreed to until
everything is agreed to
so even House Democrats who say daca
isn't their biggest priority are backing
their leader what I'm sad about is is
it's not Nancy what I'm sad is
we have chance to vote on this stuff and
my hope my job is to come to this floor
and to vote on stuff Republicans are
watching this dissent among Democrats
and see it as helpful in their quest to
keep control of the house this is a
challenge that she has decided she wants
to stake her majority or her minority on
this daca fight when the Senate's moving
forward on it we have bipartisan
agreements to reach a solution and yet
she has decided it's worth staking the
entire caucus in the house on a couple
of weeks ago Republicans pegged the
lapse in government funding as the
Schumer shutdown but this time Schumer
is on their side Pelosi is expected to
be the lone leader voting against this
spending deal and we will soon find out
how that helps or hurts for standing on
the left Chris Peter thank you